[Music]
all right and don't do drugs news Oh
coke is too good apparently submitted by
dan the man hey dan the man all right
the mother of a girl who blinded herself
while high on drugs speaks out Oh what
so she was she got so [ __ ] up that she
got blinded well how does that they said
she blinded herself like she was on
drugs maybe she was like trying to play
some food and she were up oh she went
again like this and she'll sallow to
herself is anything I don't know no
fella sometimes I get scared or like I
fear losing my vision because if I never
had vision in the first place I don't
know what I'm missing but this is like
your everything this is your one I would
rather lose all my other senses vision
100% no taste what about music no I
would lose taste in a second yeah right
away vision is important yeah I gotta
think oh what about speaking yeah I got
thing about that hmm go without talk is
that somebody's telling me like y'all
bro we're gonna go get that dope ass
excellence pizza cycle I can't taste it
but like just be like bumping into
people and [ __ ] you know like but you
know what I'm a I'm a I met Stevie
Wonder and he doesn't use a cane he just
walks around maybe his other senses
developed so much where he keeps like a
dolphin mm-hmm echolocation you up
that's what they do
so there's this 20 year old Kaley she's
from South Carolina she's cute
dope hair oh she's must be blind she
about to be by she didn't even know she
is blind
what that was her mom Kaley has been
addicted to meth for the past six months
her she don't even look you look so
clean I know yes it's the only six
months give her another six months she's
gonna look 40 that's true this could be
a photo before also yeah it looks like a
before photo meth [ __ ] you up like mug
shots of men yeah like sores get
wrinkles
you know what straight up though I'll
say this though you know you see mug
shots of people hiyo weed they just look
young and sleepy mm-hmm
they don't look old they just said the
one thing though I just don't want like
that Dave Chappelle voice and the Aries
Spears voice because they smoke yeah
yeah yeah weird voices his voice is way
different from like 10 years its way
they used to be higher right now that's
way deep enough oh the lights in her
eyes she can't see tell everyone saying
that she got addicted to meth when she
this one time she smoked marijuana that
was laced with a without her knowing
that it was late and she was like that
[ __ ] was Bob what's the other stuff in
it Canada like it's meth baby is you
like [ __ ] yeah do we just give me the
map it's like the Dave Chappelle episode
yeah and so she started getting addicted
around after she moved out of her home
and so this one day she got really
[ __ ] up on some men that was with
others but try a little primo it was a
weed with a little bit of crack and I
was in for a good surprise and I said
wow this weed is really good and they're
like that's cuz there's a little [ __ ]
primo it's a pre most crack and [ __ ] and
I was like wow I could do this to you
wow this is kind of good she got
surprised right she was like oh it's
like a cracker jack with the little toy
I didn't know I'm gonna get this so
that's probably what happened but when I
was a 13 14 I was 14 I just know crack
when you were 14 I was I didn't caught I
didn't do it
to me I was smoking a joint that was
being passed around and they're like oh
[ __ ] that's it's like Oh wake weed in
there like oh yeah that's that's cuz
there's crack in there and I was like
okay Wow okay he's like [ __ ] it I'm
already here yeah I was like can we get
more of that primo next time I didn't
know anything about like crack and [ __ ]
like I didn't know how bad it was
and that's probably how she started yeah
so the second time around
I just made the assumption that it was
laced because it led her to hallucinate
and she thought that the world was
upside down so she tried a handstand
everywhere so she went to a church she
was standing outside of a church and
apparently in this hallucination world
owners she had to sacrifice her eyes so
oh no she couldn't make it to heaven and
so she doused her oh my god
oh yeah cuz some churches they got a
bloody Jesus with us eyes like all
bloody people were saying that they saw
her in her head oh how did she get him
out I don't know what kind of mess that
is oh my god I think it was laced with
some no I mean like no it's like bat
bats all behavior no it was probably
good mess but it's my obviously if it's
working that well but it's just how you
react to it and she reacted yeah we're
trying to help her and she would fight
them all like she think with her
eyeballs
like the king in pants yeah I don't know
I mean the only way this makes sense is
if she probably smoked for like two
three days straight and she started
hallucinating
that's probably what happened dude can
you imagine being a parent and you find
out that your daughter ripped out her
own eyes in front of a church with her
bare hands dude I can't even rip off a
hangnail dude so how the [ __ ] am I gonna
take my eyes out
that's it should stay there all day
my belief is strong I was hoping that
math and all these things did something
really good to people like they're like
oh you know what I could I believe that
I could save the world and then they
like work really really hard to like
feed homeless people or like work really
really hard to clean up the streets
because you know when you smoke meth you
want to arrange and [ __ ] organize and
then they just get a trash bag and start
cleaning up everything I think that
would be awesome
but it's never constructive behavior
it's like let me rip off my ear [ __ ]
chew on it yeah you know what the [ __ ]
is that dude that's not saving the world
hey you're supposed to save the world
oh god oh sorry no I just like kind of
put my finger here and then push my eye
right there and let me tell y'all I
think this [ __ ] would pop right out
well my eyes way too small I touched it
and I was like oh I'm scared like I feel
like it's just gonna go like oh my god
your pop goes out no I can't do this
like just relax
yeah bit how is it so small because when
he goes like this
he's got smaller eyes I open the god
that [ __ ] was really weird-looking
it looked like your your [ __ ] eyes
we're gonna speak to me Oh God like they
want to give me warnings of the
apocalyptic out
filter Oh God
we're missing the best part I just
realized she's about to tell us what the
mom had to say but no things like you
know Opie this is what happened to my
daughter don't do drugs like what is her
daughter doing now well currently she's
still in the hospital recuperating wait
what does she would like home easy [ __ ]
I don't know cuz don't don't [ __ ] do
drugs without your homeys you suppose
that little they're all mapped out you
know how about David sellin your group
that one that doesn't do drugs and then
he could make sure that he'll pull out
your eyes for you yeah this is her mom
Katie she's saying that her daughter
wanted to be a marine biologist I [ __ ]
kiss those dreams goodbye you need to
[ __ ] not only do you need a CE but
you need to have a clean record cuz if
they were like oh this this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] all up on meth all the time you
can't touch no dolphins [ __ ] that's
crazy
poor girl everyone's mentioned earlier
but they were saying like authorities
they eventually took her to the trauma
unit right when they finally got her
poor girl and then at the hospital the
doctors had to clean out what was left
of her eyes to avoid any infection what
do they do hooter this dude that's like
they kill bill' [ __ ] the [ __ ] cop oh
okay but that [ __ ] was tight that's
someone who's thoroughly experimented
with many drugs I would say the reason
why you guys don't even want to try it
is because it's so [ __ ] good that
once you do no because I gotta tell you
the truth like it's one of these things
worth if you do it one time you're like
oh my god this is so [ __ ] good why
didn't nobody tell me about this how
come everyone tells me not to do it I'm
telling you straight up it's [ __ ]
good that's why people get addicted it
feels great
that's why you don't want to do it at
all don't even try it don't even put it
in don't [ __ ] do it stay away from
that [ __ ] you're really missing out
but don't you want to miss out that's
what I'm saying I have a theory that
what drugs do to you is it let's
different [ __ ] spirits in your
[ __ ] body because different drugs
they'll let different demons enter your
[ __ ] that's can I just picture you just
going to like a clinic right and then
you're telling people about safe sex and
how much it sucks
you see these condoms
these are feeling blockers [ __ ] these
things do you have any and I'm telling
you it's so amazing don't use them
because you're a [ __ ] loser you know
what it feels like [ __ ] it is like
getting jacked off with your own hand
then you put your other hand because
people don't get like why this leads to
this right so they don't don't do a
little bit of drugs but fast-forward now
you're [ __ ] sucking off a drug dealer
so you could get some a little bit of
meth can you imagine that that's a lot
of ass hard taking calm down your throat
from this [ __ ] disgusting Harry got
and then and you don't even want to but
you're just addicted he's actually a
Derek counselor oh boy I rate that trip
2 out of 10 yep probably starting off
good ended very very horrible you don't
make no regrets this is a good anti-drug
campaign do drugs get your eyes poked
out
[Music]